Nora had been to see her aunt
who was expecting a baby.
She was curious to know whether it
would be a baby boy or a baby girl.
But how can this be found?
How is the sex of a child determined ?
And is it the same for other animals as well?
Let's find out.
Sex determination is carried out in various types.
The two major types that we will focus on
are the genotypic sex determination
and the environmental sex determination.
Let's begin with the first type.
That is the genotypic method.
In this type,
the sex of a child is determined
by the sex chromosomes.
We know what sex chromosomes are.
In humans, for example,
the last pair is the sex chromosomes,
while the first 22 pairs are called autosomes.
Similarly,
in many other organisms
the sex chromosomes help to decide
the sex of an individual.
Let's take an example of mammals.
In most of them,
including humans
the sex of a child is determined by the sex chromosomes namely 'X' and 'Y'.
We know that in humans,
individuals with both 'X' chromosomes are females
while those with '1 X' and' 1 Y' are males.
This is one type of genotypic sex determination.
Now, let's take the case of birds.
It is similar to the case of humans.
But only that their system is reversed.
In the case of birds, the females have
two different sex chromosomes,
while males have both similar chromosomes.
We use the letters 'Z' and 'W'
to represent the chromosomes in them
These letters are used just in order to
avoid any confusion
with our human chromosomes.
So a female is the one with 'ZW'
and a male is the one with
'ZZ' set of sex chromosomes.
So the sex of the birds' offspring
is dependent on females.
If the mother gives her Z chromosome,
then it will be a male, with “ZZ” chromosomes,
while if the mother gives a 'W' chromosome,
then it will be a female with 'ZW' chromosomes.
So just like in the case of humans in birds as well,
the sex of the offspring
is determined by the sex chromosomes.
Wasn't this interesting ?
Now let's understand the other types of
genotypic sex determination
in the upcoming part.
Humans and birds
have an amazing genotypic sex determination method.
The presence of a different sex chromosome
plays the vital role in determining the
sex of the offsprings.
Now let's discuss the third type of genotypic sex determination.
In this case, just like humans
here we have the sex chromosomes 'x' and 'y'.
But the presence of a 'Y' chromosome
has got nothing to do with the sex of the child.
In fact, the sex chromosomes
are not the only factors instrumental
in deciding the sex of the child.
It is the ratio of the sex chromosomes to the autosomes
that decides the offspring to be a male or a female.
And which organisms exhibit this pattern of
Sex determination?
One example is the common fruit fly
or the Drosophila melanogaster.
But what exactly is this ratio system?
It's the ratio of sex chromosomes to the autosomes
that determine the sex of the offsprings.
For example,
when a fly has 'two x' chromosomes
and two sets of autosomes ,
then the ratio obtained will be two is to two,
which is one!
The flies with this ratio of 1 are females.
A Fly with the ratio of 0.5 is male.
So in case a fly, has one X and one Y
and two sets of autosomes,
then the ratio will be 1 is to 2 making the fly a male
Now tell me,
what if a fly has 3 sex chromosomes,
XXY and two sets of autosomes,
will it be a male or a female?
Give it a shot!
Let's crack this together.
If we calculate aptly,
then there are two x chromosomes
and two sets of autosomes
Thus, the ratio obtained is 2 is to 2, that's one.
So this fly will be a female.
The presence of the Y chromosome
does not affect the sex of this fly.
It's the ratio of the X chromosomes
to the autosomes that determines the sex.
Now let's talk about one more interesting type of
sex determination
that makes use of genes.
This system is called the haplodiploid system
Can you guess what the system could be?
Well, let me help you.
The haplodiploid system is the one
in which the males are haploid as they develop from
unfertilized eggs.
And females are diploid
as they develop from fertilized eggs.
This system in which males are haploids
and females are diploids is called the
haplodiploid system.
This system is predominantly found in the
lower members of the animal kingdom like insects.
Bees, wasps and ants exhibit Haplodiploidy.
There are a few more types of genotypic
sex determination prevailing in nature.
But for now,
we will deviate towards the next type
of sex determination,
which is environmental sex determination.
Let's learn about that in the next part.
What will happen to water
if kept at 0 degree Celsius or at 100 degrees Celsius?
At 0 degrees the water will freeze to form ice,
while at 100 degrees it will start to boil.
But... Do you think temperature effects only
nonliving objects?
Nope, it has a huge impact
on the life of living beings as well.
Apart from regulating various body systems,
it has a huge influence on several
important processes of nature.
Take sex determination, for example
In certain animals,
the sex of the offsprings
is dependent on the temperature at
which the eggs are incubated.
We note that sex determination
occurs in two major ways.
One is genotypic sex determination
and the second is environmental sex determination.
So temperature dependent sex determination
is a type of the latter form.
Let's look at this type in detail.
To begin with
the sex of the offsprings in some animals
is dependent on environmental factors.
The first type is
temperature dependent sex determination.
In some reptiles like crocodiles and alligators
the sex of the offspring depends on the
temperature at which the eggs incubate.
If the temperature is high then the offspring is female,
while if it's a low temperature
then the offspring is a male.
Same is the case for certain turtle species.
If their eggs are incubated above 32 degrees Celsius
then all develop as females,
while if incubated below 28 degrees Celsius
then all develop as males.
Apart from temperature dependency
what other environmental factors determine the
sex of an offspring?
Well location is one thing.
Yes, you heard me right... but location of what?
To understand this
let's take the example of the green spoon worm.
There are two possibilities
where these free-floating larvae can land.
If the larvae land on the bare ocean floor
then they turn out to be females
and on the other hand
if they land on the body of a female
then that makes the larvae turn into a male.
This is how location helps determine the larvae sex.
Isn't this type of sex determination interesting ?
To revise in a nutshell
sex of offsprings in various animals
is determined by two major types
one is the genotypic method
and the other is using environmental factors.
The genotypic method involves the sex chromosomes
that determine the sex of the offsprings.
Just like the XX and the XY system in humans
or the ZZ and the ZW system found in birds.
Another type in this category
is the ratio of sex chromosomes to the autosomes
which is seen in lower animals
like Drosophila melanogaster.
The second type of sex domination system
is the environmental system.
Animals, like crocodiles alligators and turtles
exhibit the temperature-dependent sex determination,
while lower animals like the green spoon worm,
exhibit the location dependent sex determination.
So this was about the sex determination system
found in various organisms.
To know more fascinating things in genetics
tune into our upcoming videos.
And do not forget to subscribe to our channel
to receive more interesting videos.